Thomas Hobbs was a 17th century English
philosopher who's on hand to guide us
through one of the thorniest issues of
politics to what extent should we
patiently obey rulers especially those
who are not very good and to what extent
should we start revolutions and oppose
governments in search of a better world
Hobbes is thinking is inseparable from
one major event that began when he was
64 years old and was to mark him so
deeply it colored all his subsequent
thinking remarkably he died when he was
91 and so everything he's remembered for
today
he wrote after the age of 60 this event
was the English Civil War a vicious
divisive costly and murderous conflict
that raged across England for almost a
decade and pitted the forces of King
against Parliament leading to the deaths
of some 200,000 people on both sides
Hobbes was by nature a deeply peaceful
and cautious man he hated violence of
all kinds a disposition that had begun
at the age of four
when his own father a clergyman was
disgraced and abandoned his wife and
family after he'd got into a fight with
another vicar on the steps of his parish
church in a village in Wiltshire the
work for which we chiefly remember
Hobbes Leviathan was published in 1651
it is the most definitive persuasive and
eloquent statement ever produced as to
why one should obey government authority
even of a very imperfect kind in order
to avoid the risk of chaos and bloodshed
to understand the background of Hobbes's
conservatism it helps to realize that
across Western Europe in the 17th
century political theorists were
beginning to ask with a new directness
on what basis subjects should obey their
rulers for centuries way back into the
Middle Ages
they'd been a standard answer to this
contained in a theory called
the Divine Right of Kings this was a
blunt simple but highly effective theory
stating that it was none other than God
who'd appointed all kings and that one
should obey these monarchs for one clear
because God said so and he would send
you to hell if you didn't agree but this
was no longer proving quite so
persuasive to many thoughtful people who
argued that the right to rule ultimately
lay not with kings but with ordinary
people who gave Kings power and
therefore should only expect to take
orders from kings so long as but only so
long as things were working out quite
well for them this was known as the
social contract theory of government
Hobbes could see that the Divine Right
of Kings theory was nonsense and
whatsmore was going to be increasingly
unpersuasive as religious observance
declined he himself was privately an
atheist at the same time Hobbes was
deeply scared of the possible
consequences of the social contract
theory which could encourage people to
depose rulers whenever they felt a
little unhappy with their lot Hobbes had
received a first-hand account of the
beheading of King Charles the first on a
scaffold in front of the banqueting
house of the Palace of Whitehall in 1649
and his intellectual Labor's were
directed at making sure that such
ghastly primitive scenes would never be
repeated
so in Leviathan Hobbes puts forward an
ingenious argument that tries to marry
up social contract theory with a defense
of total obedience and submission to
traditional Authority the way he did
this was to take his readers back in
time to a period he called the state of
nature before there were kings of any
kind and to get them to think about how
governments would have arisen in the
first place ketta Hobbes his argument
was that the state of nature would not
have been a pretty place because humans
left to their own devices without a
central authority to keep them in all
would quickly have descended into
squabbling infighting and intolerable
bickering it would have been a little
like the English Civil War but with
people in bear skins bashing each other
around with flint tools in Hobbes's
famous formulation life in the state of
nature would have been nasty brutish and
short
as a result out of fear and dread of
chaos people were led to form
governments they had done this willingly
as social contract
is maintained but also under
considerable compulsion fleeing into the
arms of strong authority which they
therefore Hobbes argued had a subsequent
duty to keep obeying with only a few
rights to complain if they didn't like
it the only right that people might have
to protest about an absolute ruler or
Leviathan as Hobbes called him was if he
directly threatened to kill them however
if the ruler merely stifled opposition
imposed onerous taxes crippled the
economy and locked up dissidents
willy-nilly this was absolutely no
reason to take to the streets and demand
a change of government as Hobbes wrote
though of so unlimited a power men may
fancy many evil consequences yet the
consequences of the want of it which is
perpetual war of every man against his
neighbor are much worse he admitted that
a ruler might come along with an
inclination to do wicked deeds but the
people would still have a duty to obey
this person as human affairs cannot be
without some inconvenience but this
inconvenience is anyway the fault of the
people not the sovereign because as
Hobbes adds if men could rule themselves
there would be no need at all of a
common coercive power as he went on he
that complain ahthe of injury from his
sovereign complain a--the of that where
of he is the author himself and
therefore ought not to accuse any man
but himself Hobbes's theory was dark
cautious and not especially hopeful
about government in are more optimistic
moments we want him to be wrong but it
seems Hobbes's name will always be
relevant and fresh again when
revolutions motivated by a search for
Liberty go horribly awry Hobbes
maintained in the preface to Leviathan
that he had written the book without
partiality without application and
without other design than to set before
men's eyes the mutual relationship
between protection and obedience
you